How long before you do a video
conversation with Kanye West?
Mm.
Yeah.
I mean the whole,
I don't even know what to say about
Candice Olin's.
Right.
And Chinese west.
I mean it's just observe.
So we'll see.
We'll see what happens when the sun
on the 25th we'll be listening to your
lectures.
What's your advice for balancing Charles?
Well,
there is a charter and rule 12 call,
which is short at chapter 12
which is rule number nine.
Rule is assumed that the person listening
to deal with something you don't.
Okay.
So I'm going to tell you
a story about marriage.
This is,
this is,
this is kind of cool.
So I had this friend,
his name is flow Carlstrom.
He went to Sweden to get Eric
because he was Swedish Fish,
Canadian and uh,
and the marriage ceremony,
the couple have all the candle.
You're taking your boss.
And that was very interesting to me.
And you know,
in the Christian symbolic world,
marriages,
which feature of something sick,
which means it's something axiomatic and
fundamental and not to be messed with
me.
Of course.
That's what you assume when you take,
you're going to make this a
foundation that you don't shake.
Who found again with that,
can you kind of stay in your
cell phone and what kind of,
you're absolutely state.
Can you yourself on it.
One of the things about that,
and this is worth knowing
perhaps especially to the
people in this audience who
haven't been married yet,
but maybe to those of
you who are already here,
there's an idea that means that
your marriage to Kennel work,
unless you're all in.
That's why there is he bald at the
same monogamous we're calling them,
run the world by.
He aren't really to the society,
but they tend to be very unstable
for all sorts of complicated reasons.
So there's a strong proclivity toward
social reinforcement autonomy among human
beings and there's a strong arm
liberty to make it in environment.
There's a psychological reason for that,
which is that you are not going to be
committed enough to your partner to take
care of them unless you bloody well know.
You want to shout him them that
you are shocking to the escape
because why are when you look how you're
not going to be serious enough about it
so I can really,
I have to put up with
you for like 50 years.
We better get our our house in order
because otherwise it's going to be some
slice of,
because you're just a
screwed up in horrible as me.
So,
so that's something that's very,
very serious and so with your partner
has a problem or if you have a problem,
you want to solve that because otherwise
you're going to have it maybe every day
for the rest of your life.
And you might've made,
because I could run away
and find someone else.
It's like,
well good luck with that because they're
going to come with just as many flaws
probably as you have
probably as department as,
and you're going to bring all your
insecurities and the vcs into the new
relationship anyway.
So unless you want to be alone,
which is no picnic,
and generally a fairly quick
route to the kind of insanity,
then you're pretty much stuck with
the fact that you have flaws anyway.
So they're standing there
with this candidate.
Here's the ideal,
same ideas,
Cannibal Christmas,
it's a complicated idea or something you,
most of you act out,
I didn't have lights in
the darkness of the winter.
You bring the tree inside is
what the hell are you up to?
And you don't know going to do it anyways
because of the course.
What do you want to do when
you bring a tree lights in?
It stands to reason,
right?
And what does the Y to symbolize?
Illumination.
Darks.
And it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a pagan ritual,
but it's been Christian honesty.
You put out an angel perhaps at the top
of the tree to signify that which is at
the top of things and you celebrate the
reemergence of the light to the dark
side.
So it's a little ritual.
It's eight gap laying out in the
world in terms of good and evil,
with light being good darkness,
feed evil.
And it's a good thing to do in the
winter because it's dark and you're also
celebrating the birth of the song.
It's very,
very complicated.
So,
and then the capital and
the trees assignment in the
nation and vision and like
it's a Christmas tree.
So it's associated with the idea of the
birth of the mythological hero or the
messiah that's crest until you're
doing all that at the same time.
Now celebration,
because it's a great thing,
a new hero inches the world.
That's what happened to
a child the child has,
is a locus of divine consciousness is,
is threatened at birth.
Like the mythological hero wall was his,
because he's smaller and trout trout,
if not hopefully goes
up to do great things.
And so that's all tangled up in that.
So the,
the capital is a symbol of the light in
the world and the light in the world is
the mythological hero.
It's Christ in the Christian drama.
So we'll use that.
So you hold the camera above your head
when you're getting married to symbolize
what you are subordinate to.
Because you might say,
well in the marriage,
well the wife or the husband,
that's the claim that's put out by
those who think that marriage is a
patriarchal,
oppressive institution,
which it is by the way,
which you know,
because we will need people who get
married now aren't rich people and rich
people don't oppress
themselves as far as we know.
What if you look at the demographics
as marriage has disintegrated,
it's disintegrated from the
lower socio economic classes.
And so unless you can come
up with a reason for why
rich privileged people would
impress themselves,
then the whole notion that marriage is
no oppressive patriarchal structure is
pretty much the gist fruit.
So,
so we'll say,
well,
Wireshark support it to their husbands,
but we also say,
well,
husbands are subordinate
to their wipes as well.
And Fair enough.
So,
so what is it that the couple
of his subordinate too,
and their history is what
symbolized by the light.
And so what that means?
No,
there's an old idea.
It's a very symbolic and a weird
idea that Christ was androgynous and
combination of male and female,
he was a reconstruction of the original
Abbott who was male and female before he
was old apart.
This is a dream.
It's a cultural dream.
So Christ is the property.
You need a masculine and feminine.
And so that's what the marriage is.
Just a property be masculine and feminine.
And the people in the marriage,
the husband and the wife are supposed
to be subordinate to the ideal you of
masculine and feminine.
And what that I and union is that spirit
that's created by proper and truthful
debate,
dialogue.
So what do you do if you,
if you're married to someone,
we have to contend with them and
they have to contend with you.
And that's a real bad if
you're actually communicated,
cause you're not saying you
have different personalities,
you have different values,
you have different age,
your different sections
like you're different.
And that if you can incorporate them
difference in both of you can incorporate
that difference.
Can you both why went out and you're a
full of flaws and their partners full of
flaws,
but he knows something you
don't and you know something,
he does it.
So if you can start that
information exchanged,
going,
that Turkle dialogue in both of you
can be transformed in the course of the
August speech that
constitutes the relationship,
the negotiation,
and what you're supposed to do.
And this is what symbolized by the candle
is both subordinate yourself to that
ongoing negotiation.
So you know,
one thing you don't want to do is you
don't want to beat your wife eat an
argument even though you really watch it.
I mean you absolutely want to and
you're going to act that out too.
And she's going to do
the same thing to you.
It's just not that helpful because
you have to live with her tomorrow.
And so if you defeat her in an argument,
well here's the options.
A,
she was right and you're wrong
and you just argued better.
And so what the hell is that?
She's right.
You haven't solved the problem or
you were writing and meter good,
then she's like beaten.
And not very happy about it is going to
do the same thing to you as soon as the
opportunity arises.
That's not very helpful.
So what do you want to do?
And you want to find out
what the hell the problem is,
which is really painful and horrible
thing to do because people sometimes don't
even know what the problem is and then
you have to listen to them like for three
days to clinic play without trying to
tell him what's wrong cause they don't
know and you have to be shut out.
The non offers solutions too early
because otherwise they can't go to the
painful process of figuring
out what the problem is.
Maybe it's some problem they have
with their father mistreated.
Your mother been like 1975
if you listen,
knowing that if you solved the problem,
you don't have to have it again.
Then if you could get that negotiated
dialogue going continually and that's what
you're supposed to be subordinate to.
And so then to answer this question,
which is to me here,
my wife and I were expecting some of the
25th what is your advice on balancing
childcare heritage in the business?
It's like,
well my advice is
stick to your damage bout so you can't
run away and then you with your wife
because the two of you having two brains
rather than one would probably be able
to figure out how to do this as you go.
If you actually talk to each other.
That's part of the utility free speech.
But so you get to think out loud and if
there's someone else around you is also
thinking and whose life is at twined
with yours and you both aiming for what's
good,
then between the might be
able to get the process going.
That's the,
that's the exchange of the logos,
let's say.
That will enable you to
overcome the problems of life
and then maybe having done
that and make yourselves into
a unit reasonably intelligent,
wise,
it's also capable of learning.
And then when your child
and how does that unit,
they'll be a nice wall around,
you know,
you know what it's like because they're,
they're,
they're pushing the primates and they'll
get everything they can in the wall.
They'll just purchasing the torture
torches and see if he's a weakness
somewhere.
Cause they want to know.
And if they could set
you against your wife,
they will absolutely do that.
But if you,
because why wouldn't pay?
Because they want to see what's real.
They're not messing around.
We're trying to live right.
And they want to see what they're
going to push the boundaries.
And if you have a solid relationship
and the kid comes up and pushes against
that,
it's like,
you know how when we were talking about
some of that to walk once or twice and
stand up underneath the table
needs to short snap a good one.
But because of the table
never changes shape,
he'll only do that twice.
And so now for the chicken,
people was changing shape all the time.
Or The kid would be underneath
there trying to bang his head on.
So if you and your wife has forged a
unit that isn't penetrable in some sense,
then they're going to push and push until
we find out could that doesn't work.
And then they're not going to replay that.
And that's going to be really good for
you because then your children will
torture you to death and it's really
going to be good for your child because
they're going to have tested the limits
and find out that there are walls to
keep the chaos and that's
going to make them feel secure.
And then they're wanting to be able
to develop within that security.
So that's a perfect deal.
And so that's my advice for you.
Who's having to some on the 25th
thinks that you might want to think.
I have a chapter called,
don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike
dark
as well
low.
The more you're able
to construct the dark.
And so if you pretended
that it sounds like it up,
then why should anyone listen to you?
I mean,
I know what life was like.
I spent 20,000 always counseling people
through the most difficult things that,
you know,
they were just selling.
I could,
it could help them solve a problem,
even with the best will own their car.
And we just cornered into
this new damage is very,
very bad.
But most of the time it was
a very positive experience
because very frequently
people,
even in dire straits can make your
legs look better than they are.
So,
but to do that,
well you have to have to confront what's
terrible life like just try to by 11
and so you have to,
to deal with that.
So
how should you structure the
future children's education?
What were the first thing?
And we had to little fire.
Look,
the reason you don't want to let your
children do anything that makes you
dislike for this,
because you'll be mean if you don't
mind and you're waiting or to them and
really capable of being mean.
And you might be neat because like you're,
you're the sort person who
abuses your child physically.
You know,
you laugh.
Shall we have a terrible temper?
And they're angry at
them when they succeeded.
Your brutal or you might be the sort of
person that smothers the with dependent
law and either way it can just do
them in and you can do both of those
unbelievably needly.
And if you don't like the children,
that is exactly what we do.
And they might think,
oh no you won't because you love them.
It's like,
yes you will.
That's what people are like and that's
why families are often such a stinky.
It's of catastrophe and they don't have
to be like they frequently are and lots
of people's whole life journey
is to fight their way out.
If they're unbelievably powerful,
multiple family,
that's the whole [inaudible] nightmare.
So
you want to encourage your children to
behave in a manner that makes you deeply
appreciate the fact that they exist.
Now you're kind of praised
because you're only one person.
And so hopefully you have someone around
you that's your long term partner and
say who could slap you on the back of
the head and you're being too insane
because you know,
part of what might make
you dislike your children,
just the fact that you just only have
your act together well and they're doing
perfectly,
you will key things if you
happen to be irritated about it.
And so that's part of why you need a
partner to sort of alerting when you meet
unreasonable above your match.
And hopefully the two of
you were different enough.
So you're a Melba makes you one half
decent put together person and that person
helps the child learn how to be likable.
So other people like,
so the first thing you want to figure out,
if you want your child to have a
proper relationship with being,
et Cetera,
this,
whether that's actually what you want,
you know,
because you might get hit.
Of course,
that's what people want
for their children.
It's like,
no,
of course.
And it's not.
Lots of people have terrible parents
and they're not just carrot to be them.
I mean that's bad,
but it's not.
That's something that starts neglect.
Kids can handle latch.
One does,
it's not total.
But I've had clients whose parents didn't.
Every time that person did something good,
their parents punished every single
time until they were terrified of doing
anything at all.
And either punished by criticizing to
death when they have the goal to try to do
something useful in the world or acting
as if they were absolutely terrified out
of their skeletal.
Every time a child took a risk,
which is the sort of helicopter
parenting that so absolutely Kevin Scott,
don't get upset your mother,
you know,
with your courageous and
forthright action in the world,
right?
And so then see if you do that,
then you can associate courageous action,
guilt.
If you really want to do into your kids
and then that's an excellent trick and
take the best thing about them and
make them feel horrible about it.
That's a good trip.
And if you don't think
you're capable of that,
then you're not taking it because you
are capable of and it's a real danger.
It's the danger of over protectiveness
cause it takes a real courageous parents
too.
It's so interesting.
I watched this video last night,
my wife,
she went to me,
I think it was from Russia because I
don't think this could have ever possibly
happening.
America is typically about two,
I think he's still in diapers 30 mobile.
And you know we had their parents had
put up one of those little doorways that
we put up for kids in the door that
keeps them in the room or maybe stops him
from falling down the stairs.
And so it had one of those little things.
But there's actually two.
I'm talking because this kid had and
learn how to get client to reflect and
learn a little,
the little door with the
post Nicco another one on
top and he climbed up a hell
of a time going up over the
top and he was in diapers.
If you look at that,
you think that
that's what's going to happen.
But the parents did interfere.
They videotaped it.
No,
it's not abusive.
Here's what's abusive is you wait until
the kid is three quarters of the way up.
The second one,
so like five feet off the ground and
then you have a little panic attack about
how or it is.
So then you upset the child so that he
fall and hurt himself and then you'd tell
him that's what happens when
you do that sort of thing.
That's abuse and they get to do that
[inaudible] point and it's like it's a
courageous terror who stands back.
I don't want that kid this fall,
but I'm not going to mock about movies
out there like a master in new world.
So that's what we do.
If you have some courage and you let
your children take your us because if you
don't have lumps are
going to get a lot of big.
So
you want the best for your children and
you've got to ask yourself that question
seriously because there's at least is
a big part of you that came the part,
let's say it does not want
the best for your children.
It could be an annoying
if it was successful,
that would be fun.
How they succeeded.
And so,
and if you don't think that's true that
you do not know anything because it is
your and [inaudible] and
everyone's like [inaudible].
Some people are really like that.
So when you might think that it's dark,
it doesn't have cause reality and,
and [inaudible],
what would you say to someone
who doesn't feel like he,
not while you're right,
touching.
Okay,
what do you shouldn't do is beat
yourself up because of that.
Like you're not enough and it shouldn't,
it shouldn't take you are,
because then what the hell are you,
are you going to do?
If you're already on attaining the goal,
you've got nothing to do it.
You know,
one of the things I've noticed talking
to audiences like this over the last year
and a half or so,
the audience gets very quiet
when I talk about two things.
One is responsibility.
Every medical is quiet to
cancel school because of grips,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
there's something to that.
And you know that the audience
goes quiet when we talk,
it comes up.
You know there's something in the
Internet because it's unspoken necessity
that's manifesting itself.
It's that
this issue of self esteem.
So would I be suggesting to people
psychologists plus the soil,
especially the ones that
aren't very well informed,
haven't been telling people for five
decades that they should have high self
esteem.
It's like
most of what passes for self esteem
has been shaped by a psychologist is
actually the temperamental trait.
So if you take self esteem scales
and you score heights because you're
extroverted and low in neuroticism,
so the scales are wrong,
that's one.
And number two is who the hell says
you should have high self esteem.
What's so great about,
you
know,
it's not because people are
very happy with who they are.
And so if you tell them,
oh no,
you're good to read more.
I think wait a,
I'm not very happy with
the way things are with me.
And so I was supposed to be
happy with the way I'm and I'm,
and then like,
what about this?
This read this part of my life.
And so it's not a good thing to tell
people that they're just okay the way they
are.
That's not at all.
What do you want to tell them is you
could be winging when did you are,
you could be way more than
you are and that would be bad.
That would be better for you and it would
be better for your feminist would be
better for the country to be better for
every and there's something about east
sufficient and wretched as you are.
Then could you start that,
start on that path and be successful and
so it isn't that you should be that you
should be happy with yourself
because of who you are.
It's that you should be the sexual of
yourself because you are the sort of
person who transformed herself
into and that's way better.
[inaudible].
I want to put up a little
bit boundary road that look,
I know that people beat themselves up
at the time and so it could be two jumps
medical with regards to yourself
and that means getting aggression.
I notice of anxiety.
Can you really have and committed suicide?
You got out of it despite the fact that
you thought of anything you could be,
you have to have a little bit of
mercy that you're touched towards you.
So if you don't want to,
you don't want it.
You want to treat yourself with
someone that you're trying to help.
Right.
That's another talking,
talking to treat yourself like you're
someone who responsible for help and that
regards to the detachment.
Imagine that you're worthwhile
despite your analysis.
And then if necessary in the world,
at least in the bowl,
it's to help.
And I think that's absolutely the case
because you could certainly generate,
it'll help yourself up too much.
So you've been at least not do
that and that would be important.
So it's reasonable to treat yourself
with a certain amount of detached to the
SPEC and then the garden himself
to someone you should try to help.
Like you would help someone
character in a detached sort of way.
Because if people have melanin,
if other people have value,
then you have melted and you load yourself
the same ethical responsibility that
you owe other people
and maybe what you want.
What other people is the responsibility
to help them along the way so that the
world gets better rather than worse.
And so that's the same attitude
that you should think to yourself.
So despite the fact that you're
not all that you should be,
despite the fact that you have plenty
to learn and they should learn it,
you don't,
you also don't get to beat yourself to
death with a stick all the time because
you're in submission 50 different ways.
So justice,
that's the judgment and mercy is what
enables you to tolerate the judgment.
And you need to use both of those forums
to discuss the proper relationship with
your life.
And so you're not enough.
Thank God for that because you wouldn't
have anything worthwhile to do if you
were to not do,
which is to make things
better than they are,
including yourself.
And so
[inaudible]
do you pray?
I don't ask God for fees.
And I think that's what people do.
Pray
prayer is actually something
that works but asked him,
cause that doesn't work.
You could ask to have enough
courage to see the truth.
And that's a painful thing to do.
So for example,
here's the,
here's the prayer of sorts.
So imagine you're having a fight
with your wife and it's only you.
It's like it's this sort of
fight that makes you women,
whether he should be in
the damn relationship.
And so,
you know,
every fight you tending in that direction,
which is awesome,
why can't we won't have flex up
that entire space of catastrophe?
And it's part of the light.
You want to be serious about it.
You don't want to open up
to the possibility that you
could leave every time you
have a fight.